l'enquêté a établi que si l'auteur effet
bénéficié du patronyme de l'enseignant
du monde et de la localisation du
collège
en revanche il ne disposait pas des
moyens lui permettant de l'identifier
aux sentiments situation n'a été rendu
possible que grâce à l'intervention de
collégiens du même établissement
c'est dans ces conditions que le parquet
antiterroriste a décidé de déférer
devant les juges d'instruction donneurs
dont l'application dans l'identification
de la victime au profit du tueur est
apparu comme provence il a en effet
reproché de s'être matin en présence
direct et prolongé d'abdul hack the
rough l'après-midi du 16 octobre après
ce dernier leur a fait savoir qu'il
souhaitait entrer en contact avec
monsieur samuel patty est d'avoir permis
l'identification de ce dernier on le
désigne et ce contre rémunération il
ajoute en effet les investigations qu'à
son arrivée aux abords du collège vers
14h un moule à quant aux aurores cherché
à identifier sa future victime et
abordait pour ce faire un élève en
offrant une somme de 300 350 euros le
collégien qui acceptaient se voyaient
remettre une partie de la somme et
l'acheter sur place avec l'auteur des
faits jusqu'à l'arrivée d'autres
camarades
peu avant 16 heures certains se joignent
à l'heure à lui après qu'il a expliqué
l'objet de sa mission
ils ont offert de partager la somme
d'argent d'autres refusaient de résister
le canadien qui a reçu l'argent
accompagné dans ses camarades donnant
une description physique de ses nus elle
pâtit à tous la case of ces derniers
jours a déclaré avoir l'intention du
film un professeur de l'obliger à
demander pardon pour la caricature du
prophète dans les milliers dans le
frapper c'est normal que le chien se met
à peu après à l'écart avec abdul haq en
europe afin semble-t-il de ses dix
musiciens et des caméras de
vidéosurveillance et d'un véhicule de
police en patrouille
la proximité peu avant 17 heures
plusieurs adolescents aux liens avec les
premiers désigne l'assaillant jeu samuel
pâti au moment où il sortait du collège
doit quand joe roff remettait le
reliquat de la somme au premier
adolescent et se lance alors à la
poursuite de la victime